good morning everyone
my name is natan mish and today we're
going to have a session on data
validation for data science
first of all it's very exciting to be
here after two years we were confined to
our zoom rectangles so it's good to see
faces in person too
today's session is an hour and a half
it's an interactive session so feel free
to stop me if you have any questions
just raise your hand i'll try to spot
you
and you can just shout your questions or
problems and so on
take a look at this code just has anyone
seen this before
i see a few nods so
this is the kind of error you get if you
run even a very basic model so random
forest regressor
with very few features and your input
has now values so
sklearn for this matter will shout at
you for having null values and this is
something that i've encountered many
times i'm sure you have as well many of
my colleagues and this is the kind of
thing that happens
if we don't check our data we don't
validate it before we
try to run it or try to fit it and this
is the goal of today's talk to
convince you that the practice of data
validation validation is essential and
i'm also going to show you a few tools
that are available in the open source
arsenal of python that you can use for
this matter some of them are actually
pretty cool
um so a few words about me i'm a machine
learning engineer at zimmer environment
which is an orthopedics medical devices
company
a few years back i did i did a master's
in social data science at the london
school of economics and previously i
worked at the finance and fintech
industries
and another thing about me is that i
like finding bugs i actually love it and
especially if they're my own making and
that is one of the reasons that i went
on this journey of exploring uh data
validation tools and actually
incorporating in the products that my
team is building
and hopefully
i'll show you a good a good show of them
today
so today's agenda uh but first i'm going
to
try to convince you why do you need data
validation
and then i'll go over to show you uh the
hands-on kind of like practice of
the different tools you can use
for different steps in the machine
learning or data science life cycle
it is important to say that i've chosen
tools and fit them to steps in the data
science life cycle
just for simplicity but each of these
tools that i'm going to show
can be also used for different steps
um
and another thing is that
i am focusing in maybe in the way i talk
or the way i present it at
production systems but you can also use
it if you're running experiments that
you iterate on and you run them multiple
times you probably need data validation
steps in those experiments too even if
you have a hobby project that you're
building a model
in your spare time and you don't want it
to fail when you run
maybe a large training job for example
so you probably need data validation
steps there too
what we will not cover is how to
optimize your validation holdout data
set for deep learning models
the
title of this talk might be misleading
so if you were here for that
i won't be offended if you get up and
leave
so the three notebooks and three tools
we're going to look at is first we're
going to do validation in databases
using great expectations then validation
and training pipelines using pandira
and finally validation in model serving
using pedantic
we might not have enough time for the
last one but all of the notebooks that
i'm going to show here and play with
are available online in my repository so
you can just clone it and all of the
notebooks are self-explanatory you can
run through them yourselves
i'm just here as a bonus
so instructions for the tutorials um
there are two ways you can go through it
so either you clone the repository
locally and you have your own python
environment and jupyter installed and
use that or if you navigate to the
repository on github you can
just
go navigate to each of the notebooks and
then click open in colab
and then it will open up in google
collaboratory and you can run through
that
that is if you have a google account
which i guess you do
so take a few maybe a minute to navigate
to the uh
to the repository set it up
see that you have it and it will
it is all okay
oh yeah let's try that
oops
i can just show you on here
so is this better
she goes
okay we get it
yeah i'll take that as a yes
all right so let's crack on then um the
data set we're going to use for our
tutorial is a very famous one quite
common in tutorials and data science uh
training inside in general it's uh it's
on kaggle you might have encountered it
before it's the kaggle house prices uh
prediction competition
it's a data set on
houses in iowa united states and
different features about them how much
they were sold for and that's what we're
trying to predict it's simple to use and
understand um
there's a variety of features about 80
in total from different different types
and that is useful for our case because
that's what we'll be trying to check
different types and so on and how how
are we using them
so what does data validation actually
mean so data validation is the practice
of checking the integrity accuracy and
structure of data before it is used and
as you can imagine data validation is
not only essential essential not only
for
data science projects or even software
projects in general but any kind of
work that uses data probably should have
data validation steps in place so if
you're working in insurance and you have
enormous excel sheets you probably need
data validation um
and if you're working in research and
you're getting a new batch of data then
you should probably make sure that it is
all okay
um the kind of the kinds of things we
can check for when doing data validation
are endless we can validate types ranges
consistency
and
mostly for our data science use case
we want to incorporate the business or
the research logic to make our project
more robust
how can data become invalid um
there are multiple reasons
the first one which is probably uh comes
up to mind first is human error so for
example if you have annotators
annotating your target variable
they are more than likely to make one or
two mistakes
let's say in our data set that will be
practicing imagine there are people
doing the surveys and typing in uh
different things about the houses that
we are trying to predict the prices for
and
it's not uncommon for those people to
maybe add a zero to a house a price or
maybe
leave out a zero
so those are the kind of like human
errors you can do but
obviously there are
many many more you can do
another thing is outdated or expired
data sets
that's something that is fairly common
so for example in our data set it is
from
let's say a survey comes from
2006 and we are trying to predict for
house prices in
2022. and so that might be might make
our model um biased
um and finally there can be bugs or
changes in upstream data pipelines so if
for example you're consuming data in a
production system that doesn't come from
that you are not responsible offering
you just a consumer then there might be
a change in that upstream source that
you are not aware of and you should be
aware of and by putting data validation
steps in hand you are
more prepared for that kind of scenario
i could go on about this um but i can
just let xkcd
explain this to us better so in this
cartoon here there's a few engineers
talking to each other and one of them
comes to his colleagues and says check
it out i made a fully automated data
pipeline that collects and processes all
the information we need and his
colleague asked him is it a giant house
of cards built from random scripts that
will all completely collapse the moment
any input does anything weird
and
obviously it does
so the reasons
to
put data validation steps in place uh
first one we want to maintain data
integrity and data integrity is a
concept when you build software that
essentially
guarantees the quality of your data and
once you put data validation steps in
place in your data science or machine
learning
product then you help align that data
integrity throughout the whole system
now data integrity usually is split into
two so there is the logical
data integrity which is what we actually
care about so that is the content of the
data but there's also the physical data
integrity so
if that data for example lives in a
server form somewhere
we want to keep it
healthy and
and alive there but that is not
something obviously we are responsible
for unless it's on-prem and it's our
responsibility but that is a different
problem
second is reliability of our system or
experiment or project we want to prevent
and detect bugs from the very first
interaction with the data
but then we also want to prevent and
detect them throughout the data science
product life cycle we want to minimize
the surprises we want to know
what input are we expecting when are we
expecting it and it can also help us
with an early detection of a data drift
so data drift in data science projects
is the concept that when your
data set for training pipelines is much
different that when you then the data
you are actually doing the prediction or
classification from
um i gave an example earlier so for
example if your
house prices data set is outdated or
expired
and then you are trying to do a
prediction based on those outdated
data points that might be a problem
third is readability we can harness
python's type hints feature um for our
purposes so you know how you can use
typings in in python and i'll show it in
the notebooks afterwards
to make
our code more readable and that is a
very nice feature for these data
validation tools and python
working together some ides will even
highlight if you have a problem
with the types you are sending back and
forth in between functions and classes
and so on
which is really nice
fourth is familiarity so by implementing
validation steps it will force us to get
to know our data better and as data
professionals we are expected to know
our data and
we when you when we are putting in place
these data validation steps then it will
force us to look at them look at the
types uh look at the different limits
and
and then know how our data looks like
some of the tools i'm going to show here
even have
features for automate automated data
catalogs and data documentation create
creation which is really nice
um yeah so that was familiarity
and now a question for you so at what
point in the model life cycle should we
implement data validation and this is a
very simplistic kind of like diagram of
how
machine learning or data science product
looks like
so where would you think we should put
data validation steps in place
anyone
so i argue
we should put data validation steps in
all of these places
pretty much pretty much everywhere
so from the very first interaction with
the data at the data ingestion
[Music]
step we want to make sure that the data
we are consuming is what we expect it to
but then also when we are doing data
preparation which you can also call
feature engineering we are manipulating
and changing the data that is the
definition of that step and we want to
make sure that when we are doing that
we are not
um breaking anything and that everything
will work as expected
then in model training we are passing
the data let's say maybe for through a
few
neural networks we want to make sure
that
through each of these steps the data
comes in and comes out as we expect it
to and there are no surprises and
finally and the very last bit when the
model gets deployed let's say we are
serving a prediction or a classification
when we are getting a data point and we
are supposed to make a prediction for
that
first of all we want to make sure that
that data point is
as we expected to as the model expects
us to be
but also when we make that prediction or
classification that the prediction
is
in the structure that we have defined
so now we will start with the hands-on
tutorial before i jump in are there any
questions about anything i have just
mentioned
no
okay
all right
so you can all see my screen right um
so for those of you using collab
you can just navigate to the notebooks
here
and you can open and call up by clicking
this here
and this will present the
notebook
did you all get to it
is it working fine
yeah
okay
so first thing we will do is install the
required packages and import them to the
notebook so by running this cell here
you can authorize this notebook
i guarantee i have not put any sql
injections there
[Music]
yeah that's true
so this will install
the packages we need
and then we are
go after it has been installed we'll
import the required packages into our
notebook
okay cool it might ask you to restart
the runtime to
get the packages in our kernel
once you do that you should have
you should be able to import the
packages
all right
and we can crack on so great
expectations is an open source tool it's
named after the famous 19th century
novel and i guess that's also where this
lovely picture comes from
it's a shared and open source package
for
ensuring data quality and it helps us
eliminate pipeline depth through data
testing documentation and profiling
so
it is a great tool
that you can implement as i've said
before at any step of your
of your data validation journey and
every step of the data science product
and what's really nice about it is that
it has many useful integrations with
tools you are probably already using so
it can be connected directly to sql
databases apache spark airflow bigquery
and many more
but you can also implement it on file
systems so
even a local file system if you have it
locally on your local machine or
azure blob storage data lake gcp bucket
and so on
with great expectations there there's
quite a steep learning curve with all of
their different terms
um
it's okay i'm here to help you with that
we'll go through it hand by hand
there is this dictionary here we won't
go through all of these terms right now
because they'll just mean nothing to you
but as we go along and we set up great
expectation in our project we will
encounter them and then i'll explain
each and every one of them and what they
mean
so the first thing we want to do is
create a data context
well and the data context is essentially
the first step in our great expectations
journey
and it is it will hold all of the
definitions
and all of the configurations for great
expectations in our project when you run
this cell right here
so
this will initialize
great expectations data context and it
will create
locally this
folder here
so this folder will hold
first of all the configuration for um
for our project
but it will also hold the expectations
which we'll go over later those are the
actual assertions and
logic that we are putting in place
for our data um the checkpoints uh which
we'll also go over which are
the specific points and the definitions
of how to do them and when to do them of
of the data validation
process
in place
and many more things we won't go over
all of them right now i think i've
covered the
most important things
this is another explanations for for
what happens in that directory
and there is this nice diagram from the
great expectations documentation uh
which shows actually what is in the data
context and what we and what we have
there
so we'll go over each and every one of
those things
so don't you worry
first thing we're going to do is create
a data source
and for to do that the first thing we'll
do is get the get the data context we
have just created
and now we will script a yaml file that
will create a data source so obviously
you can do this here in a notebook but
you can imagine that
in a production system it will be like a
shell script or something more fancy but
to make it more simple and for
all of us to understand i broke it down
into different cells in the notebook
so first is the data source name and
what is a data source actually
data source provides a standard api for
accessing and interacting with data from
a wide variety of source system
and
an easy way to think about it is that in
a data context you can have multiple
data sources for example in your project
you might be consuming from a sql
database but you might be also consuming
from a file system somewhere
and by defining multiple data sources
you can handle all of that within the
same data context
next we're going to define the execution
engine
so
great expectations to actually perform
all of these checks and all of these
computations there needs to be
an engine underlying doing all of those
computations and here i've defined
pandas execution engine just because
it's the easiest tool and i'm sure that
all of you if not most of you know it
but alternatively you can also use a
spark execution engine
if your project is pi spark oriented
or you can use a sql alchemy execution
engine if your project is
sql oriented
moving on we're going to define a data
asset and a data asset name and a data
asset is a collection of records within
a data source which is usually named
based on the underlying data system and
slice to correspond to a desired
specification
so for example in
our data set which is
comprised of different surveys for
houses and their prices throughout
different years
we can say that there were multiple
surveys throughout many years and one
data asset is one survey from one year
so the hierarchy is we have multiple
data sources and for each data source we
might have multiple data assets
next we're going to define the data
connector so the data connector provides
the config details based on the source
data system which are needed by data
source to define data assets
quite often mouthful but what
essentially it means is how do we
connect to this data asset and that's
what we're doing here
what we what we will then do is combine
all of these conflicts into one
dictionary
which is this dictionary here
and we will script that dictionary into
yaml file
and great expectation provides this nice
method called test yaml config which
actually
makes sure that your yaml configuration
is okay and you didn't do anything wrong
so running that
will tell us that we have
we will successfully instantiate a data
source we haven't really
added it to our project yet and to do
that we'll run this cell which is add
data source
and we'll add our data source conflict
to it
we can see that it has been created
successfully by running this cell and
congratulations you have now got a data
source in your data context
next on comes the real uh core of great
expectations and and um the thing we are
actually all here for so creating a
great expectation suite and an
expectation suite is a collection of
expectations
what is an expectation it's an assertion
about our data
and once we will see some of the
examples it will become more clear
so how do we actually
build or write or define our
expectations there are multiple methods
again
thanks to the great guys at great
expectations we have this diagram here
that shows a few ways you can do it
so
one way you can do it is by looking at
the metadata and then creating custom
scripts
you can also use your own domain
knowledge so if you're already aware of
the data that you're working with and
you know the different limitations or
maybe you've even
been instructed what are the limitations
you can just straight ahead write config
jsons and add them as an expectation
suite to your project
another way you can do it
is by using profilers so great
expectations offers automatic profilers
that look at your data runs through them
scan them and then gives you all of the
different ranges types and
basically conclusions it reaches from
the data
what we'll be doing is a bit of both its
introspection so we'll be going in the
notebook looking at the data as we work
through it and then building
expectations from it
and in this way we'll create an
expectation suite
so first step would be to read in our um
data file
for for our meter and this is using this
read csv method right here uh it will go
to the repository pull that file from it
and and just read it in and this will be
pandas data frame for for all sorts of
matters but it will also have on top of
it a few uh data expectations
properties and methods that we're going
to use in the same way you can also use
read excel read table parquet and so on
so let's take a look at our
pandas data frame
and see how it looks like
so
as you can see already there are many
different features um
and obviously each and every one of
these features will have its own
limitations and things we should be
aware of
so the way to um
actually see what expectations you can
already put in place is if you're in a
jupiter notebook if you go to this cell
and then you put your cursor here and
then you press tab it will open up all
of the different expectations you have
but if you're in prolab like me
then you can
do oops
you can do something like this
and then
it will list all of different methods
and
and properties this
data frame has and we can see already
all of these expect methods so
you can see expect distinct values to be
in set expect most common value to be in
set and so on and this lists all of the
different checks that are already built
in and great expectations that you can
just use out of the box
and what's really cool about great
expectations is that you can also build
your own custom expectations and use
them in your project
not only that you can use
you can upload your great expectations
sorry your expectations your customer
expectations that you've built into this
public repository of expectations here
and
it won't load right now for some reason
oh it's still loading
um but you'll see here there are many
many more expectations that were
crowdsourced essentially and there are
many many cool ones for example i saw a
few days ago there is an expectation
for a column
that holds bitcoin wallets to make sure
that that bitcoin wallet actually exists
so it goes and it interacts with the api
checks that that bitcoin wallet exists
and that way it validates and that is
the expectation essentially
so let's create a few expectations um
first one is quite straightforward and
easy we expect the id column in our data
frame to exist
so by running this cell right here
it will
run this check it will run this
expectation it won't add it to our
project yet
but it will make sure it will validate
that it is actually valid for our data
frame
and
you can see this flag here success
equals true which means that this is
valid for our data framework
we can also
add an expectation called expect column
values to be unique
and this will check that all of the
values in our
column are unique another useful thing
is that it shows how many values it had
actually scanned through how many of
them were missing and then if there were
any unexpected values it will count them
here and show percentages and so on
um
but what happens when an expectation
fails so let's look at that
in this one i have defined the
column max to be between 0 and 100 000
which i know doesn't hold
let's see what happens when i run that
so
if i run that
it will first of all say success equals
false but it will also
tell me what was the observed value that
made this expectation fail and as you
can imagine this would be really useful
in a production system if you want to
know what caused your expectation to
fail
few other useful expectations so we can
expect column distinct values to be in
set
so
we run this
um it will see it will show you the
actual values that were observed um
so this column here is actually a string
column but from looking at the data here
we can actually know that it is
expecting these
only these values here and i guess if
you're working with the data you will
know that
this is kind of a zoning feature and
there's a zoning category and these are
the expected values and accepted values
we can see this was successful
moving on we can also expect the column
mean to be
between two between a range in a range
uh so
we can also add that and it will tell us
what that actually what that mean
actually was
so after we've ran all of these
expectations
what uh great expectation can do is that
it can collect all of these expectations
into an expectation suite
by running this
method right here get expectation suite
and you'll see that it has collected all
of the all of these successful
expectations we have just ran
and we'll put them together in one
expectation suite those that have failed
it will leave out
and also if you've had duplicate
expectations it will also leave out the
duplicates
if you do want
the failed expectations to be near
expectations tweet there is this keyword
here that you can use discard failed
expectation
and you can use that
to add that expectation suite to your
data context you'll use the save
expectation suite method and we'll call
it my expectations and by running that
it will add this json file to our expect
great expectations directory
um
and and and that is that is that about
expectation suites are there any
questions at this point
about any of this
yes i believe so um
i don't remember it by heart but i've
seen it before yeah
anything else
no okay so we will do a short exercise
and this is not uh
any test or quiz uh don't worry it's
just for you to play around with that
great expectations yourselves um
so
there are a few definitions here a few
expectations that you are asked to put
in place and you can put them here
and just play around with it and see if
it works for you
not all of the expectations that you are
asked to put in place here were
mentioned
in what i just showed so you'll probably
have to find them in the expectations
directory which i've just showed you in
the great expectations website
so take a few minutes to do that
let me know if you have any questions or
any trouble
and
yeah let's take about four minutes let's
see
um
foreign
checkers
uh
i'm
but
okay
okay how's it looking
did anyone encounter any issues
no
this is a friendly reminder to drink
water today is supposed to be the
hottest day in london since i've moved
here essentially so
very important
okay
so it looks like there were no
great issues otherwise other than the
great expectations not really working on
m1 with condo forge
which is unfortunate but m1 has its
limitations we all know
so let's look at the solutions and if
you
if you go to your to the github
repository
and
you
look at the notebooks directory
there is exercise solutions here
and these are
the solutions for this exercise right
here so to check that a column is of
type you just expect column values to be
of type to check for null values you
expect column values to not be now
column min is
defined this way if you want to define a
column median it's this way
and
the last one which might have been a bit
tricky is expect column most column
values to be in set
so
if sale type is a type of categorical
type of column and you have multiple
categories so you define here what are
the what is
the set from which the most expected
value should be
any questions about that
no okay cool
so moving on um and the last bit in this
notebook here would be to actually
validate the
actually validating the data in a data
checkpoint
and a checkpoint is the primary means
for validating data in a production
deployment of great expectations
so
a checkpoint can be put in multiple
places as i've mentioned before so you
can put it at a data ingestion level or
the training pipeline level or at the
serving level but let's say you we are
doing this for a database and we are
appending a data batch to our database
uh we'll call this checkpoint databatch
appended
and then we are defining the checkpoint
in this way using this config
and we'll use the same
definitions that we've used before so
you remember how we defined a data
source this is the data source we're
going to use we've defined the connector
and the asset data asset and so these
are
things we have defined previously now
we're going to use them in a checkpoint
and it also asks us which expectations
we to use and we're going to use the
expectation suite we have just created
so running this cell will add a
checkpoint to our data context project
it will still not run the checkpoint it
is just a definition of how to run it
as you can see here in the object it
returned in this dictionary it has an
action list
what are the things it's going to do
when it runs this checkpoint so the
first thing it will do is it will store
the validation result it will run
through the data scan it and all of the
output from it the result of that scan
would be stored
it will also store the evaluation
parameters all of the things that we
have just defined and it will also
update the data documentation
we won't have time for it in this
tutorial here but i really recommend
looking at the great expectation data
docs feature it's a really nice feature
that
creates
a data catalog automatically from your
data
so
to run this checkpoint we'll load a
different file another file so
the home data test file
and we will run the checkpoint on this
file here so
running this cell will create a batch
identifier and batch identifier contains
information that uniquely identifies a
specific batch from the data asset such
as the delivery date or query time
and running this
you will see that
this little progress bar here that shows
you um how far it has gone along and
calculating the metrics
and it will return the result object we
can which can then later look at and see
what are the results for this
check for this checkpoint
so looking at the results object we can
extract the statistics for this
checkpoint and for this batch and we can
see that it has evaluated four
expectations and all of them were
successful
but you can also look at a specific
expectations and see how it looks like
how the scanning for that expectation
what are the statistics for that
so running this cell
you will see that for this expectation
that if you remember we've defined a
specific category and we've defined it
to have a
certain set of specific values that it
can hold it has counted how many
occurrences there were in this data
frame of each of these
values but how does a data checkpoint
that did not succeed look like so
we are going to create basically a bad
data column we're going to inject a
duplicate value into our id column
and this will basically make our
data frame invalid because remember how
we defined before that we are expecting
to see unique values for the id column
and we will define this checkpoint same
way as we've defined the other one
and we will get the results
looking at the statistics
what we will see is that one of these
expectations was unsuccessful
and
looking at the specific statistics for
that specific expectation
we can see that
there it comes with this useful
information that it tells us how many
unexpected values were found
and how many
and what were those values actually so
we can see that
this value here that was the one that
caused trouble
and obviously it did not succeed
any questions about that
no
cool all right so we'll move on um and
now we're progressing if you remember
the diagram i showed we're progressing
in the
data science life cycle or machine
learning life cycle and we're going to
perform data validation in the training
pipeline and
for that we're going to use a different
tool which is called pandira
has anyone heard of pandira out of
curiosity
see one two hands maybe three
yeah yeah it's i think from all of the
tools um in this tutorial here it's
probably the least
known one
um but it's it's
immensely useful and
my team has implemented it successfully
and we are very happy with it obviously
as any uh kind of like young or
uh not yet not that well known
open source tool it has its limitations
and
um
but it still it works for us and and we
love it
what is good about pandira is that it
integrates it's built upon
pandas which is a common tool for all
data scientists and
the data scientists in my team they use
pandas quite a lot as you can imagine
and pandera
is just a really really neat natural
integration for doing data validation in
their training pipelines or in their
experiments
um
so yeah so
let i hope you navigate it to this
notebook here and installed all of the
different tools we're going to be using
then we're going to import them into our
notebook
we're going to read in the data
and first thing we will do is try to
train a basic model um
and we're going to use the most common
like scikit-learn
tools for that so we're going to create
a pipeline for that pipeline we're going
to create a custom class that chooses
features
and for this example we're just going to
pipe that
choose features column into this
pipeline here we're going to choose
these feature names
i've chosen them just because they're
the most simple ones and will be useful
for our for this demonstration
so we'll define this pipeline first step
would be the feature selection
uh second would be a standard scalar
that you probably
all aware of and it's quite common in
these types of pipelines and then
finally a random forest regressor
the choice of model was arbitrary it was
just for the purposes of demonstration
so then once we've defined on that
if we try to run this pipeline here
it will scream at us saying the input
contains nulls
which as we've seen before is something
we are trying to avoid
and the tool that will help us with that
is pandera
and pandira is provides a flexible and
expressive api for performing data
validation and data frames it has many
useful features uh some of them
are it can perform hypothesis testing so
not only um just checking like
basic things as we've seen before so
types and ranges and so on can also
perform hypothesis testing it has you
can use function decorators
to implement it in your pipelines to
make it more readable and less heavy on
your code
it is using the pedantic style syntax if
you've seen that before
um which helps with readability
um
and many many more things so
moving forward let's start working with
pandera and see how it looks like so
first let's add another feature to our
features
and create
pandira schema and this is how it looks
like
so this is a very very basic schema
for our
training data and what we are defining
here are two columns or two fields one
of them is an integer and the other is a
string
obviously we'll have more
we have more features in our data
but just to show the very basic schema
um
this is how it looks like and when we
run
this uh when we run this validate method
on our data frame using this schema
it will validate that what we are
serving it is actually
it actually uh confirms to this schema
so running this
will do the validation pandara does the
validation and it returns a data frame
um which means it has succeeded now as
i've mentioned there are more features
here
and we'll see uh in uh in the rest of
the notebook that there is a way to say
check that only these uh
features are or or columns are in the
data frame but there is also a way to
say
i expect these features to be in but if
there are more
then uh then it's okay and this is
actually the default behavior that you
see here so we've only defined two
so it checked for those two but there
there were more features or there were
more columns which it basically ignored
and the way you can define these types
for the fields or the column you can use
multiple different ways so these are
some of them you can use numpy data
types you can use strings you can do use
python types and so on
but what happens if there is a bad data
schema or a schema that doesn't fit your
data
so we're defining here notice how
one of them is different from before so
before we've defined a lot config to be
a string
now we're defining it to be a float
and this would throw an error
so
pandira raised the schema error saying
expected series lot config to have flow
64 and it got an object
instead so
[Music]
besides checking for types you can also
check for ranges and you can also
say that
a certain field or a certain column is
not nullable using this flag here
so running this it will check for these
ranges here
and once we see we get a data frame back
it means that this check has passed and
it's all okay
but what happens if you want to catch
the data so for example you run a
checkpoint you run this check against a
certain data frame and some of the
values were not what you expected so you
want
in a production system what you would
want to do is probably not make the
system break and stop uh throw an error
like we've seen but you want it to
continue
isolate that data that we saw put it
aside and then continue with the rest of
the data so to do that
we're going to take a sample of the data
just to make it easier
and
define this
bad data scheme i call it and
in this schema right here year built
i've defined it to be in the range
between 1900 and 1990
and obviously in our data set we have
houses that were built before that so
this will uh
if pandira will check it it will throw
an error
and you this is how it happens as you
see here it says that
um this check has failed and these are
the failure cases
and
to overcome this we can use a tri-accept
block
to catch that bad data and a tri-accept
block is actually a common practice in
python it might not be so common in
other languages but in common in python
it's actually okay and it's encouraged
it follows this concept called eafp
easier to ask for forgiveness than
permission
and
by using that um
we can isolate the failure cases into a
failure cases data frame and this is how
it will look like
so
we get
the column here built this is the check
that has failed we get the failure case
which is the actual value that made the
the check fail and we also get that
index
and by using that we can create a filter
data frame with only the accepted values
that we are accepting
and once we run the validation on that
we can see that we're all good
did that make sense
yeah okay cool
um as we've seen before we can validate
acceptable categorical variables so
let's say we've defined
accepted values for lot config we run
this
we
define this pa check is in these values
and that will make sure that the values
in this column are only from this set
and we see that we have a schema error
because we haven't added this uh value
to our set
as you can see here
there are many other useful methods in
this check class there are some of them
are listed here but not all of them and
you can go on the pandira documentation
website see all of them it's um
you you can probably find a few that
will be good for your use case
moving on
we can use
a flag called coerce so let's say we
have this uh field in our data frame
called lot area and it's an integer
and we can use this coerce flag to
basically tell pandira whether to force
the type we are defining on the data if
possible or not
so
we are defining a lot area to be float
um but we're setting cores to false
meaning don't force it on the data
and
running this validate method will throw
an error but if we do the same using
chorus equals true
it will force the flow type on an
integer type if possible
i'm not saying this is good practice i'm
saying that it's possible
and another useful fact is strict so you
remember how i mentioned before you
don't have to define all of the fields
or all of the features in your schema
you can define a few of them and have
pandira only check for those you have
defined but using the strict flag
i you tell it to make sure that only the
fields that you have defined
are in that data frame
so
you can either use strict equals true
but you can also use strict equals
filter which what it does is that if
there are any other fields in your data
frame it will filter those that are not
defined in your schema
and this is how it looks like
any questions so far about pandir yep
why
that's a good question um
i think
it's a matter of
usability
and
the
in your t your team or yourself who use
the tool so we found that uh the data
scientists in our team are
picking up pandira more easily
and
i think that was the main reason
also you might consider using a tool
which has
a more
a bigger community
so for example pandira i think has yeah
it probably has a smaller community than
great expectations so
if you if you want something that is a
bit more reliable i would say go for
great expectations but as i've said
before we use pandira we love it and and
it's in our production system um
it's just yeah things to consider
any more questions yeah
compared to great expectations andera
doesn't seem to have any validation or
distributions
so i think you're right
but what you can do is hypothesis
testing
so
we won't go over this uh
in this notebook here but
using hypothesis testing for example
let's say you have
a column that is called gender in your
data frame and you want to validate that
the male and female gender are
somewhat distributed uh in a
in an equal way in your data frame so
you can use hypothesis testing for that
does that make sense
yeah
any more questions
yeah
sorry i couldn't hear that
yeah so
so the way my team is including that
step in the pipeline is in the future
engineering steps we include
pandira decorators that validate let's
say if you have a function that does
some kind of feature engineering step
that anything that comes into that
function is of a certain schema and
anything that comes out of that function
is a different type of schema
it's a good question uh yeah obviously
not only in pandira uh pandas also is is
known to handle
uh larger
data sets not as well as other tools
in our use case we our
data frames are not that big
but if they were bigger then yeah we
might consider using something else
anything else
okay cool
so
we have a short exercise here
yep
just to practice defining data frame
schemas using pandira and how to do that
so
there are a few definitions here that i
ask you to try to write in a pandira
schema
some of them we've gone over here but
not all of them
you might have to go to the
documentation for that
uh the very last one is a bit harder so
that's a bonus if you want to try it
but let's take yeah as before maybe four
minutes to try and do that
and if you have any questions then let
me know
is
let's go
so
okay
okay how's it looking
did it make sense
let's see
let's look at the
solutions to the exercise
okay so
this is how the solutions look like so
we're defining the id column to be an
integer it is required it is not
nullable and it has to be unique
uh then the zoning field as we've
mentioned before
it has to be one of these values
and so on
um checking for range looks like this
checking for string a string length
looks like this
and the rest of them are pretty
straightforward
the one that was probably a little bit
harder is this chex one so notice how
these are checks that you run for each
column let's say you have a check that
you want to run for multiple columns
as we've
defined here
so the first floor square feet and
second floor square feet columns
on average the values of the first floor
square feet should be greater than the
second one which makes sense if you
think of a house usually the first floor
it has more square feet than the second
one
and to do that you run this checks you
you add this checks um
value here which is outside the columns
definition and in here you use a lambda
function to check for the mean
and you define it to be less than the
mean of the first four square feet
okay
all right um so we have 15 minutes left
i think
we'll start with the
third uh tutorial the third um notebook
we won't have time to finish it but
for any of you who want you can just
pick it up
after
all of the notebooks are pretty
self-explanatory
[Music]
and also this is probably the
most commonly used tool out of the three
so this is using pedantic
to check for
data in model serving so data validation
in model serving
and
yeah just out of curiosity how many of
you have heard or used pydentic
yeah quite a lot yeah
um so the first step would be
authorize this notebook
and install pydantic
and while it is installing um
just
so we're on the same page what do i mean
by actually model serving so this is
again a very simplistic diagram of how a
machine learning or data science product
will look in production so we have the
training pipeline which we've shown
before and we've put data validation
steps before in there we package it up
into a model which is a pickle file or
an onix file or any kind of other type
of format that you're using and then we
are serving we are handing it over to a
serving or inference layer and in this
layer what you have is either a virtual
machine
or a lambda function you can have it as
a docker container in kubernetes and so
on um
but what happens in this slid in this
layer is that this interacts with the
outside world for that matter so you
have an application or you have someone
triggering this inference layer
using an api so it sends some data using
an api to this layer and then
the in the serving uh layer
it sends back the output so the
prediction or classification and so on
and what we want to check is that
whatever comes in here doesn't mess up
our model and that's what we're going to
use by dantic for
and pedantic as i've said before is
quite yeah it's quite a
popular tool a lot of
great projects you're probably already
using
have pedantic in them integrated even
the jupiter
project is using fidentic
so yeah
so
start we'll start by reading in a data
frame and we'll choose the features that
will come in to our model
and usually when we get this type of
file in
through the api or this
data batch it will come up as a json
file or text file or csv file and for
our purposes here to make it as simple
as possible we're going to mimic it as a
json file so this dictionary right here
and this is how it looks like
and as you can see already here we have
an l value which as you've seen before
will probably
cause havoc in our model
so the way you define
a model so the very basic building block
of pydentic is a model and in a model
you define an object and how it looks
like and you put all of your checks and
validations onto that model so
we create this class by importing the
inheriting the base model of pedantic
and we call it input
just means this is the input to our
model and in here we define all of the
fields that we are expecting in this
input so those are all of the fields
that you've seen before
and we can use this input class
to create an input object from the
object we are mimicking so the object we
have created earlier
so we are instantiating it in this way
and assigning all of these values to it
and this will be our model input object
and already as you can see
it has thrown an error because there was
a validation error on the lot frontage
field
so the value is not a valid integer as
we've seen it is not
um
so let's say your model can actually
handle
null values and it's okay and you're
allowing it and you know how to handle
it
so one of the nice features about
pedantic is that it incorporates the
native
typing module from python so you can
import these
classes here optional in any and you can
define that lot frontage will actually
be
any kind of value and it will be
optional meaning it can be known
and then we can
define this object
as before but a simpler way to do it
instead of defining each of the fields
and
putting some value into them you can use
this
double star syntax in python to unpack a
dictionary and just
insert it to the
to the model
and once you've done that this is how
your input object looks like
so a few other cool features from
pydentic is first of all you can use
recursive models so you can use a model
you've defined before and incorporate in
another model so let's say we have an
input batch
which is a bunch of inputs coming in
together at the same time we are
defining it as a list of inputs
and let's say we are creating this
dictionary of multiple inputs
then we can
we can then uh iterate over that
dictionary and insert all of it into an
input batch which would look like this
another useful feature is emamps or
enumerations
so
you can define a model so pedantic model
that has a set of predefined values and
if you remember this ms zoning feature
from before
you'll remember that we have
a specific set of values that we allow
for this for this feature and by
defining this ms zoning class
using enums
we can incorporate it into our model in
this way
and now moving on to something a little
bit more complicated but is very useful
is custom based models and this is based
on
a problem that we have encountered in
in our production experience in my team
that
the fact that we were able to create
custom-based models helped us
overcome that problem so
the way to access certain fields or
certain
values in a pedantic model or a pedantic
object is by using this dot notation
like this
and what happened to us is that we were
consuming
data that was coming in for from a
source that we had no uh control of
and we were expecting one of the uh
field names that we were consuming to be
of a specific name
and
at some point after we have built an
entire system that name was changed
and what that meant was is that we were
using these dot notations in multiple
different places and
what that meant is that we had to
basically do a huge
uh find and replace across multiple
repositories multiple projects and yeah
it was was a bit
of a waste of time
honestly and the way we decided to
overcome this if this ever happens again
is by using this extended base model
and we've extended inherited from the
base model and added these two methods
to it
and what that meant was is that not only
we can use the dot notation but we can
also use a bracket notation
so
let's say we want to access this year
built
field in our object we can just do this
now with a bracket notation
and what we then added is a class four
field names
and
in here we have defined what are the
field names for each of our objects and
then
whenever let's say if a field name
changes in our upstream source ever
again we only have to change it in one
place and not in hundreds or thousands
of places
then we can use it
as such
as before we can catch bad data as i've
shown in pandira so
let's say we have this input class which
is again it's a bad one it doesn't fit
our data
it will break probably if we run it in
production
we can incorporate the same tri-accept
block that i've shown you before
based on this python concept that i've
mentioned and we can show
first of all what is the bad data
and and see what what type of check has
has failed
um
another thing that is used quite
extensively is custom validation so
we can
define this function here of
a certain type of custom
check that is harder to incorporate
maybe within the
basic base model
and using this validator function let's
say for the garage area we are expecting
it to be greater than a thousand
by using this validator decorator
in certain the field name we can check
that it is actually
less sorry greater than a thousand and
if we get anything
bigger than that
it will break
cool um
i think
we don't have time for the exercise
there's only six minutes left so what we
can do
is if you have any questions at all
about any of the subjects or tools that
i've mentioned here
now will be a good time
yeah what's the definition of the most
60 percent
i think uh i think it's probably the
mode
so the most common value
yeah so it's saying
uh the mode has to be one of these
values
any other questions
separation
i see you you're saving the expectations
json file yeah is it a matter of
creating a great expectation in it in
each environment and then instead of
committing an expectation of jason
saving it
i think
i think the way i would do it is
create different data context for each
environment
um
and yeah i would create an expectation
suite in the dev environment and then
transfer it like send it over
to the production one
but the data contexts have to be
different because you're also defining
different data sources probably and so
on
so
yeah that's the way i would do it
it's a good question um
i think it's a matter of trial and error
uh so
you i think you start with a set of like
uh rules or logics that you have either
from domain knowledge or by profiling
your data either automatically or
manually
and then as you move on let's say you're
building a product you will probably
encounter problems you will probably i
don't know i have no values in your
gender column so you will have to put a
check in place if you haven't had one
already so i think it's an iterative
process of trial and error until you get
it right
yeah you never you'll never get it right
the first time
um i think
great expectations has really really
nice profiling tools if you let's say
you're handed over
like a data set you've never seen before
you can
scan it through with an automatic
profiler which will suggest
maybe even sometimes even hundreds or
thousands of expectations you can
implement
with a few
lines of code
um
i think the other factor to consider as
i've said before is how big is the
community so the community for pedantic
is quite big
and there are many many tools
pretty pretty complicated ones that are
using pydentic and yeah and if you go to
the github page there are
millions of people not millions but a
lot of people who are asking questions
that are problems you'll probably
encounter if you try to use it to
so i think
yeah those are the two main kind of like
reasons
any other questions
no
okay thank you for your time i hope you
enjoyed it
you